Es nimmt die Fälle an, in denen viele
Menschen einen Verlust
verursachen würden, aber Sie tun es
und Sie, wenn Sie wegen
der Kampfbestände nicht entlassen werden. Wir fühlen uns heute hier im neunten Kongressbezirk geehrt, um Gerechtigkeit zu haben. Der Vorsitzende von Seymour
würde Ihnen etwas Liebe wünschen  Mann, das ist
mein Kongressbezirk, ich möchte, dass das alles bestehen
bleibt
, bitte zeigen Sie ihnen ein paar Gesetze.
Applaus,
Jackson Lee ist hier.
Danke, mein Kollege Jackson Lee ist
[Musik]
und der
Kommissar, der Vater der
Bürgerrechtsbewegung, an der hier beteiligt ist
Texas
One, den wir kennen und lieben, den
ehrenwerten William Alexander Lawson,
er verdient etwas Liebe,
Alexa,
ich habe die Kommissare Ellis und Garcia vermisst
, liebe Brüder,
und hör zu, Garcia,
es ist wichtig, dass ich dir dies sage, die du
heute hier bist, liebe Familie,
stehe mit dir  wir werden über sie für dich da sein
, nein, sie sind nicht allein,
gib ihnen etwas Liebe hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Privileg, Flaggen über der
Hauptstadt
wehen zu lassen, für die wir es tun
Ich möchte, dass Sie wissen
, warum diese Flagge bei wichtigen Anlässen gehisst hat, dann ist
es hauptsächlich
[Musik], dass
diese Resolution denen sagen wird, die
durch die Zeit schauen,
dass zu dieser Zeit einer
unter uns lebte, der
fremd ist
Wir haben die Verantwortung gegenüber jedem von
ihnen
, sicherzustellen, dass wir
nicht weggehen, nachdem
wir sein Leben gefeiert haben, und nicht den nächsten Schritt tun, um
der ehrenwerten Karen Bass zu gedenken und die Zukunft zu beruhigen, unter ihrer
Führung, die jetzt
eine Anwältin gegen den Gesetzkongress ist
Es ist gegen das Gesetz, dass
wir die Sklaverei überlebt haben, aber
[Applaus]
fremd